[Musica]
Allora Gianni rappuoli
sono Globo ritagliaretto di una grande
azienda di moda italiana che ha sede in
tutto il mondo circa 300 negozi
ci occupiamo di produzione e vendita di
diciamo generalmente accessori e
abbigliamento una grande azienda
italiana una delle veramente poche
rimaste
5.200 dipendenti metafore produzione e
circa 2500 Si occupano della vendita io
mi occupo della parte vendita Appunto
e mi relaziono veramente con tutto il
mondo viaggia tantissimo e mi considero
estremamente fortunato Sono molto molto
contento di quello che faccio
Perché mi dà la possibilità di
ovviamente di essere in contatto Un po'
con il mondo No lavoro con generalmente
ragazzi giovani e ho la possibilità di
vedere i cambiamenti del mondo Quello
che quello che che viene quello che che
in crescita quello che è in declino a
partire dall'Australia Giappone Cina
Medio Oriente Europa a finire per
Santiago del Cile in in Sud America
come è iniziato tutto questo è partito
tutto da Sartiano ha detto la nostra
amica Sarteano provincia di Siena 4500
abitanti 4.500 anime
un paesino con valori molto sani Oggi
veramente apprezzo Sono veramente
contento di essere nato lì di aver avuto
un'esperienza di crescita Lì però
ovviamente un paese dove io ho vissuto
un'esperienza un adolescenza che ho
vissuto con molte insofferenze no in
sofferenze perché ovviamente la mancanza
di opportunità la mancanza di
confrontarmi con persone diverse no
persone che possono venire da altre
parti del mondo che vuoi imparare dove
puoi prendere cose nuove e ovviamente in
sofferenza anche per l'opportunità di
lavoro
tutto questo Insomma ho fatto anche
ragioneria anche male perché
sinceramente la scuola non mi sia diceva
molto sono anche bocciato a Ragioneria
Immagina che qui ci sono tanti studenti
pensate voi Ecco qua Infatti
universitari livelli alti o sono
bocciato e ragioneria non ho la laurea e
però lavoravo sono entrato nel mondo del
lavoro durante l'estate l'estate anche
per rendermi un po' indipendente dai
genitori No per le piccole spese
quotidiane che un ragazzino può avere
sono entrato nel mondo del lavoro a 15
anni è stato un po' battesimo del fuoco
perché lavora a differenza della
famiglia
e della scuola ti insegna una cosa
importante non sei valutato per quanto
produci per quanto
Per quanto rendi alle aziende no
e dunque Insomma rendi conto che il
mondo fuori è un po' diverso da quello
che vedi in famiglia o anche a scuola
finita finita la scuola sono c'era poco
da fare sinceramente mi sono messo a
fare il muratore perché ovviamente
volevo essere indipendente e potermi
togliere qualche piccola soddisfazione
ovviamente in sofferenze continuavano a
crescere ma non per il lavoro di sé per
sé Perché sinceramente apprezzo anche
molto un lavoro manuale no dove tu vai a
fine serata vedi quello che cosa hai
fatto ho costruito un muro lo vedi no è
solido è bello però Ecco appunto in
sofferenza perché pensavo che c'era
qualcosa oltre al paesino e la realtà di
un paese scappato di casa almeno 25 anni
lasciato gli affetti e quello che vi
dico durante il corso di questi 10-12
minuti ripeterò sempre una parola
importante uscire dalla comfort zone
dalla zona di comfort no Come si dice in
italiano comfort zone
era mi sentivo che dovevo uscire
mettermi in discussione ho lasciato
famiglia e cari amici qualcuno anche qua
fratelli e sono andato a Londra per
un'esperienza che doveva essere
inizialmente sei mesi per imparare la
lingua sono stati 16 anni
lì e sono entrato prima a fare i
magazziniere perché purtroppo la lingua
in Italia in inglese soprattutto ai miei
tempi era
Basic scolastico Dunque praticamente
quasi niente dunque cominciato a fare i
magazziniere
in un'azienda italiana e anche lì
comfort zone dopo un anno era un piccolo
mi era diventata un po' tipo Little No
tutti italiani ci si divertiva se
andavano a mangiare la pizza Mi sono
detto ma qua sto perdendo tempo Devo
accelerare devo
mettermi sul mio bagaglio culturale
delle esperienze nuove per poter
crescere sono andato un'azienda inglese
è stata una sofferenza non li capivo e
loro probabilmente neanche capivano me
cioè inglese proprio un livello molto
più alto però ecco lì Diciamo che forse
ho imparato l'inglese poi sono poi
entrato in una grande azienda italiana
del lusso all'epoca
e anche lì Sono entrato tipo magazzino
amministrazione
e lì il tempo passavano intorno ai 28
anni 29 anni ho detto qui non posso
veramente perdere tempo sono andato a
scuola mi han fatto delle scuole serali
ho studiato informatica web designer ci
ho fatto nulla però insomma ho studiato
e
al lavoro la mattina facevo il
magazziniere e il pomeriggio mi sono
messo nella parte vendita Dunque
imparare tecniche di vendita a crescere
conoscenze eccetera no
e ve la faccio breve carriera in questa
azienda direttore della boutique mi
hanno dato un altro negozio poi gestivo
l'e-commerce e anche lì poi comfort zone
devo imparare della realtà nuove sono
andato a lavorare per un grande reparto
mestolo a Londra grandissimo da parte
mestore
vi racconto questa aneddoto la sera
prima sono andato davanti no era tipo le
11 di sera e l'ho visto Sembra il
Colosseo fa paura Ho detto Madonna Io
domani non ce la faccio
4.700 persone da gestire non ce la
faccio la mattina mi sono svegliato Sono
andato al lavoro ho preso lo scooter a
metà strada mi sono fermato e mi viene
da vomitare Cioè mi sentivo proprio male
non ce l'ha fatta e poi fondamentalmente
è andato tutto bene insomma le paure
erano un po' anche eccessive e lavorando
cioè L'esperienza è stata ottima
bellissima una grandissima esperienza di
lavoro il departe mestore ha vinto
quattro volte di fila miglior departe
mestolo al mondo Dunque qualche
contributo Forse l'abbiamo portato
comfort zone ho detto no se un giorno
vuoi essere in un'azienda fanno un ruolo
globale devi conoscere l'Asia all'epoca
2013 Si parlava solo che vicina e io
sono andato in Cina
io quando sono andato in Cina c'erano la
mia azienda
circa 10 negozi e quando sono venuto via
ce ne aveva 45 e per me la Cina non è
stata un'esperienza direi un'avventura
andavo su città che non avevo mai
sentito nominare mai io conoscevo che
Shanghai begin poco più etico la verità
c'è un duo Forse c'erano i panda
e tu e tu stabili tutto il giorno la
mattina viene affinata la mattina alla
sera non trovavi e non c'era un
occidentale erano tutti cinesi
fortunatamente sono molto carini molto
accoglienti e poi anche se sono tanti ma
insomma sono sempre
accomodanti come si dice in italiano e
dunque c'è stata veramente prendi sempre
tutto con il sorriso vai avanti è
un'avventura insomma anche lì credo che
il lavoro e l'esperienza è andata bene
Abbiamo fatto un ottimo lavoro e la mia
azienda mi ha detto torna in Italia che
vogliamo replicare il lavoro della Cina
lo proviamo per replicare in tutto il
mondo
sono adesso da cinque anni questo ruolo
globale basato a Milano
Viaggio tantissimo
per dire delle parole che forse magari
vi interessano no Come come come come è
successo questa cosa a partire da un
piccolo paese senza scuola e arrivare
magari a un ruolo Global
Io credo che si parte sempre con tanto
umiltà
mente aperta a imparare da tutti ci
vuole tanto
spirito degli adattamento
ho fatto anche un anno breve dove
gestivo il Giappone e dunque conosco il
Giappone è piuttosto bene e ti deve
adattare diverse culture mai pensare di
essere superiori agli altri anche se a
gente magari si comporta in modo diverso
da noi Quello dipende da da
preoccupazioni e culture background cioè
culture diverse
umiltà
mettersi sempre in discussione
e poi ho una cosa che chiamo
Self discipline che è la disciplina di
te stesso cioè sì la determinazione
ovviamente è importante le le Skills no
Come si dice le abilità ovviamente sono
importanti Ma alla fine
sai la disciplina di te stesso di andare
sempre avanti anche quando si incontrano
problemi nella vita e non arrendersi mai
no questo ti dà ti deve dare la grinta
di dimostrare a te stesso non agli altri
di mostrare a te stesso che si può fare
meglio si può fare sempre di più
anche quando ci sono problemi e non
belli nella vita che io come tutti ne ho
passati per esempio io ho 21 anni ho
avuto una malattia cronica ce l'ho
sempre intestinale dove ho avuto anche
un bel po' di interventi e che devo
prendere medicine tutti i giorni però
questa cosa qua
non ti deve fermare non devi trovarti un
ostacolo
devi Anzi dire Ok mi arriva questo passo
questo e
chissà che sarà la prossima ovviamente
di vivere vivere all'estero vivere
lontani da casa non è facile Io
sinceramente non mi sono mai pentito di
aver fatto tutto quello che ha fatto
anche perché poi nella vita a un certo
punto purtroppo sono più giovane 50 anni
51 dici sempre questo l'ho fatto perché
avevo fatto quello no dunque c'è una
catena di eventi che in qualche modo poi
scongiungono no Ovvio con delle
difficoltà io ho perso i genitori a
distanza di tre quattro giorni l'uno
dall'altro Ero in giro per il mondo Mia
mamma è malata di SLA Io spero che
nessuno di voi sappia che quasi lo
auguro che nessuno sappia di cosa sia la
SLA perché è una malattia atroce e e
gestire una roba del genere quando ci
hai quando sei in giro del mondo con
degli impegni di lavoro che purtroppo
poi c'è anche un po' di nel mondo del
business se non guarda in faccia nulla
no devi portare i risultati devi
lavorare però ecco ripeto niente Deve
scoraggiare no e prendere la vita
è sempre con positività Svegliarsi la
mattina e pensare di essere positivo
anche perché alla fine al di là di tutto
Ricordiamoci che dico sempre questo
anche a tutti i miei ragazzi in giro per
il mondo Ricordiamoci una cosa siamo
molto fortunati che abbiamo una cosa una
importantissima che vale più di tutto
soldi
famiglia più di tutto Abbiamo la vita Ok
grazie a tutti grazie grazie grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]